انظار العالم اتجهت بالامس الى رحله رائدي
الفضاء السعوديين ريان برناوي وعلى القرني
بعدما اكمل الاستعدادات النهائيه منطلقين
نحو الفضاء وسط طبعا الاهتمام برحله رائي
الفضاء السعوديين هناك نصائح تلقياها ايضا
ولكن من شخص مميز جدا من هذا الطفل هذا
الطفل هو الطفل السعودي الشهير هاشم
العلوي اطلع عبر فيديو
هذا الفيديو شدد فيه على ضروره الالتزام
بنصائحه طبعا
ضروره تجنب استعمال العطور كذلك ايضا عن
ضروره الالتزام بالتمارين الرياضيه
امام هذا الكلام علقت الرائده ريان برناوي
شاكره هذا الطفل الصغير على نصائحه وواعده
اياه الالتزام بهذه النصائح كما تمنت له
مستقبلا فضائيا مميزا يلا
يلا
طريقه حكي وبتجنن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات